on va faire un toc toc toc spéciale
chansons de johnny et oui on sait que
vous aimez les toc toc toc vous allez
nous dire qui et qui a fait le meilleur
toc toc toc sachez que je dis sur les
toc toc toc c'est julien courbet qui
avait gagné et julien courbet donc le
tenant du titre hashtag toc toc toc
aller j'appelle en premier je vais
appeler aller valérie bénaïm ces partis
valérie bénaïm pour le premier tac toc
toc spéciale johnny allez-y toc toc toc
qui est là les ja ja qui les apportent
du pénitencier bientôt refermée et moi
c'est moi
sophie davant là tu dégages vous votez
hashtag toc toc toc version beauté
puisque 100 km à l'est j'appelle le
lourdaud thierry moreau c'est parti à
les beauty look attaque qui est là c'est
diego diego qui tiago libre dont sa tête
pères et les nuages fenêtre à ça du tout
c'est nul
mais elle est nulle salah diego libre
dans sa tête oui elle est nulle
mais il fait genre le rebelle tuant
leurs revenus fixes j'adore regarder
éthiciens les battles asie enfin brute
est le coup de pression thierry moreau
et les fous
allez on appelle tout de suite j'ai
allez on va se faire plaisir
je vais appeler mon jus combes et allez
julien combes et attention
juju et regardez bien la tête et
regarder bien l'attenté du gard a quand
même qui est là c'est monde d'hier
moundir qui moundir d'amour enchaîner
des mourants vrai sosie lors de tout
dire à gars qui croit vraiment qu'il
leur semblait même saisie de merde qui
vous intéresse vraiment le gars il est
dedans quoi mais 150 euros et un repas
chaud dans les univers
pour l'instant c'est ma préférée monde
d'hier la manche et le est et c'est le
tenant du titre de toc toc toc
et oui il s'est passé quelque chose
d'assez tenant du titre qui vient de
passer et ses rires oui il se passe
quelque chose allait on appelle tout de
suite jean-michel baer c'est parti ça
rigole déjà qui est là alli alli qui a
lui même fait le zizou
elle cherche hanté secondes est-ce que
vous avez déjà entendu johnny dia
allez-y les zouzous mais cité d'art
qu'elle conserve bon allez j'appelle
tout de suite
enora malagré aller et là c'est comme
comme qui je sais pas qu'elle nous fait
penser dit moi parce que j'arrive pas à
trouver les noms mais aussi du droit
c'est ça mais ça relève céline renaud
merci valérie bénaïm merci allez on
appelle tout de suite matthieu delormeau
après restera les trois champions quand
même gilles verdez isabelle morini bosc
et jean luc lhemanne ce qu'est il ya
neuf personnes sont retournées
allez-y ce que j'aimerais ce que je peux
frapper qu'est ce qui se passe je peux
frapper très bientôt dès la tristesse du
gars qui fait une imitation d'abord à
d'ailleurs fait la rente est là sur un
caméra
allez-y oui loi dite toc toc toc est
libre
j'ai fait toc toc question wen lauret
qui est la chicken issa kane sortie
ressorti un vieux t on sortait pas
bonsoir dépendent attention va faire le
toc toc toc c'est bon vous êtes prêts
j'appelle isabelle morini bosc
oh my god isabelle morini-bosc alesi qui
hélas ces gens qui s'ils oublient
favorisa belles robes des revenus
j'appelle jean luc lemoine jean luc
lemoine
allez-y beau jean luc toute attaque qui
est là omar on appris au mari vous avez
tout le mal que ça
pour dire aux téléspectateurs
il ya quand même une personne depuis
qu'il a fait c'est omar qui il ya quand
même quelqu'un qui est très premier
degré que c'est omar sy s'est passé le
premier omar qui me passe par la tête
quoi omar sy situe sa b2 bord de l'eau
on a un problème parce qu'à 4 3 pour des
mais colas qui déménage le plateau la
enora malagré qui souffre est
franchement ce cas les copains qui vont
arriver des casses toi tu web abbas et
non la place pour tout le monde pour
toute la famille même les déménageurs
bretons on n'a pas besoin de vous en
aller
le dernier gilbert baisse c'est parti
mon fils gilles taq taq qui est la cgil
bachil gilles qui gilles verdez j'ai
rien trouvé
après quoi ma gueule mais qu'est ce
qu'elle a ma gueule inversiones